[Music]
so victoria's secret recently announced
their uh very first
what do you think i would say underwear
i think i know very
personal the very first secret angel
oh g-string but with the space for a
penis
the very first i like that secret 2022
you get all options now yeah
g-string with space for repeating like
you know because
it's usually a flat triangle right in
the front but then now because we got
lots of options there's a there's like a
little
3d triangle
they got like little doritos 3d
yeah they got like crotchless panties
you just put your dick through that oh
if you want it covered it's it's that's
just a banana hammock it sure is yeah
it's a sock so they uh cam was right
they unveiled their first ever male
ambassador for their gender-free
clothing
pink you guys remember
that line pink yeah you know but who's
the ambassador this guy better be famous
yeah this guy but it's bret man rock is
it no it's not oh
good one
it's not it's so good it's darren
barnett you know him right oh yeah
they're [ __ ]
they [ __ ] up yeah they should got
bretman why did they get bretman rob i
know bretman would have fun he would
have been perfect [ __ ] this guy darren
uh darren barnett he's an actor he's on
uh never have i ever he's on american
pie bro that's a drinking water wait he
he's uh he's on loveheart he's the guy
from loveheart with uh you know jimmy
yang yeah and uh nino dobrev he's a he's
in uh american pie
not that one which one like the older
one the other ones
that's the underwear that they're going
to sell
no
it's not uh it's pink it's it's like
their apparel he looks so sad to be the
first man i don't know who he is i think
they dropped the ball by not getting
breakfast they're shorts and tank tops
and [ __ ] like that's their pajamas oh
yeah yeah so he's going to be wearing
those those that's baby tees and
like sweatshirts sweatshirts
oh is that does it look it looks kind of
like it kind of dude that should look
like the pacsun's cancelled samples
i'm glad he's here
yeah yeah yeah i don't know anyone more
genderless than bretman yeah bro
genderless yeah cause that fool was like
um for wears a skirt and goes oh i
needed some extra air today or something
he's actually jacked he is guys
he's athletic too my good start my girl
was showing me his uh his coachella
outfits my god he's oh my god he's so
lean and i was like dang dude this guy
can pull off anything what do you think
of the new pink line
i got that scooter oh no
that's the wallpad they had to do this
whole news story just for this
kind of a letdown right yeah like the
humber on the left looks like she's
wearing macy's like pajamas from macy's
i feel like i get that [ __ ] at [ __ ]
walmart bro yeah like actually walmart
got more fire [ __ ] parking lot of a
kohl's
where they got the clothes
clothes
from
that's some clothes uh clothes vibe i
feel like walmart got more fire [ __ ]
right now
wow walmart got way more fire [ __ ] what
do you think of this one then
look at that that's a third grade
tie-dye project
that's what you do that's like arts and
crafts with your kid
what do you think nick i don't like it
not feeling it yeah if christian don't
like it he's the authority
i have no opinion on fashion most of the
time why did he roll up his sleeve like
a condom
wow are you supposed to roll him up like
that yeah you be rolling your condoms up
bro doesn't it look like it though
it's the stylist oh you mean like when
like okay i see what you mean how do you
put on a condom cam
he rolls it up he's like why are you
even using them in the first place be an
adult bro that's how i put it on
oh man it's all like that because he's
abstinent
very cool very cool man they don't got a
team for this stuff
i love these roasts well it's like for a
company as big as keeping a good the
good [ __ ] a secret for real man do you
think that that's a good choice i
thought they were coming out with the
male lingerie
debut
and then he was gonna like be the star
of it because i'm like that's more
bolder dude this stuff should have came
out like eight years ago
yeah it kind of looks out of date right
it looks like they took a minute to roll
it out like
okay well let me show that were they
going out of business too or something
yeah victoria's secret i think so they
were closing some stores yeah
yeah you guys like this isn't it
like
yeah has it been being doing
so is it are those like jean
joggers coachella merch this is like one
step away from bleaching a rock shirt
[Laughter]
god
i like the socks i don't particularly
like it but i also don't dress like also
the like
like the photos suck
oh [ __ ] like like they didn't pick they
don't have there's no concept aren't
they like dad style photos where it
looks like a dad's taking them with this
dead camera it's kind of lukewarm it
just looks like they took it on the
sidewalk
which they did
true dad style photos the subject should
be like
flipping off the like [ __ ] [ __ ] you
dad's not taking pictures of me i don't
want you to take pictures of me
whoever's taking the picture like his
fingers like [ __ ] reluctant pictures
i like the idea of that
i like the idea of a dead core photo
shoot where even the photographer shoots
it like that your finger
that's on brand because even now going
like this
like if tyka's doing something cute i
want to take a picture this was already
like this
like no paparazzi type of [ __ ]
yeah yo what kind of guys are they
trying to market towards what do you
think yeah we think lame guy
losers
bro what what state of america do you
think that's targeting uh like they're
talk they're targeting a middle school
in connecticut
like that's a huge market dude there's
so many middle schools the connecticut
middle school kid is going to want to
buy
a victoria's secret pink
their moms are going to buy for yeah is
it like abercrombie very malcor
like abercrombie or not it's probably
the same does abercrombie even have a
demo anymore
are they still wrong i think they're
making it they're trying to make it that
that documentary really [ __ ] singed
them it's out right now the one about
the racist stuff yeah they're racist
they've been they've always
had a netflix dog
that just released where it's exposing
their whole like employee handbook and
like what like the guy they would just
wanted white cheerleaders or something
yeah who to hire who the demo is like
what's not allowed what is allowed and
it's like all racist [ __ ] oh but didn't
they have some [ __ ] like in our
generation where the ceo was just saying
like i don't want these [ __ ] chinese
people buying up all my [ __ ] or like
whatever and that's who was buying it
all up chinese people
for a little bit bro honestly be happy
you're making money yeah seriously your
clothes are selling be happy
[ __ ]
like you're winning bro
be racist if they're ruining your
business yes
you're literally winning dude
you know when i was a kid i thought
racism was cool because i was like
i was like you're absolutely right no
because i was like i'm in your country
right i'm like treat me like [ __ ]
because when you come to my house i have
the right to treat you like [ __ ] too oh
so did you invite any of those people
over like racism i was like duh i mean
you're i'm in your country of course
you're gonna treat me like [ __ ] that's
how i thought as a kid that's kind of
funny dude yeah well as a kid so you
didn't feel like this was your country
no yeah so like as i was just like a
minority right so like in junior high
like let's say if i were to have heard
that like they have their own handbook
they only want white people working and
i'm like duh it's an american store with
american workers
that's the most practical way to let
that's how it system
i thought i would have beauty i'm like
you come to [ __ ] my dad's like
restaurant he's gonna kick your ass out
yeah you know because abercrombie get it
too yeah
that was like what were you in high
school during abercrombie's like reign
of supremacy yeah so was i and i really
did think that like and it was like a
default acceptance like oh yeah that's
like white cool white people go there
yeah yeah yeah you're just kind of like
like abercrombie and [ __ ] because i
never [ __ ] work
i have a comedy a [ __ ] because i was
like
i don't shop there i go to [ __ ]
anchor blue [ __ ] blue dude hey that's
true multiplayer yeah
i think i went before when it was called
miller's outpost yeah
because one day i was like i'm not going
to the swap meet no more i'm going to go
get my t-shirts at miller's outpost
that was the spot three jeans for
[ __ ] 25 but i wonder if that's if
that's like a
is that like a
a thing that changes with time because i
feel like when when we were in high
school and it was like you would see a
store that was so clearly
for white people that you just didn't
even think about you're just like okay
that's not for me those stores didn't do
good in this area back in those days
hugo boss did good but i don't know i
don't know what like what's the goal
today is the goal today if you see
another story that looks like it's
geared for whites to go in there and be
like where's all the asian [ __ ] like
what do people want now
oh yeah i think it's i think do they
want them to change do they want to
include something for everyone i think
white's not in anymore i think every
there's like a i think even with culture
there's like seasons of coolness because
in the 90s i feel like if it was white
it wasn't even mainstream white it was
like it was like grunge or it was like
underground and like that kind of grimy
culture because even like in hip-hop and
like the stuff that was becoming
mainstream was like street gritty [ __ ]
right because it's like it was like it's
either you you you're into like you know
like kind of like black culture like
like ghetto stuff or like whatever's or
like like the rock [ __ ] right
you didn't have many choices but then
now i think it's the opposite i think
it's not cool to be white at all it's
actually like the it's like it's like
cool to be so unique or indigenous or
whatever
i think it's flipped because that's more
[ __ ] up because now other people that
aren't a part of that culture they're
profiting off of that style
oh yeah you know the thing that did make
me sad about abercrombie back in the day
was that like it was very clear that all
the guys that worked there were these
good [ __ ] looking white and black
dudes
and the only other you didn't see any
like asians in there other than hot
asian girls but there were never any
asian dudes because it was very clear
that they didn't think asian guys could
sell like they didn't think that was the
look but they had hella fine asian girls
so then you looked at that and went
ah damn like
i'll never be like a good enough asian
for that asian girl like she's obviously
gonna default to like never got that
because i just thought everyone in that
store was full of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's what i thought
i thought they were like none of these i
was like none of these fools they never
even committed a crime i'm like i wanna
talk
but there was definitely there was
definitely that's what was interesting
too is that like
like it was still cool to be like a um
i guess a peace loving good-looking
white guy but it to be an edgy asian you
had to be a [ __ ] crime asian a crime
that was the other identity yeah like
you had these like rugby shirt wearing
white dudes that girls still loved but
asian guys weren't cool unless you were
[ __ ] santana
yeah it wasn't enough to be clean and
painful where you grew up though it's
like different role models right because
like in the south bay
it was half and half like you were
either like because there's a it's a
huge skate and surf and extreme sport
culture so then like i grew up with a
lot of japanese kids that did like
either that or they were like nerdy
or like they're into the hip-hop [ __ ]
like the ghetto stuff right or whatever
because like the the neighborhood was um
super black and japanese so then like
a lot of the kids they they either grew
up and gravitated because they they they
hung out you know in that crowd or
the the next city torrance in redondo
beach that was more white and then
they're more into skating and all that
stuff
and then so like when i came to the sgv
it's all chinese kids right and none of
them do sports
like extreme sports they don't have a
basketball league everybody's [ __ ]
doing batman some wacka [ __ ] or
they're hardcore [ __ ] gang members so
you're going to the gym and you see
these tattooed buff-ass chinese gang
members and [ __ ] and then like it's just
a different world yeah no one's wearing
everyone's wearing like raiders jerseys
kings jerseys and no one's georgetown
jerseys yeah no one's wearing that stuff
at that time yeah so when i like you
have asians dressing like cholos out
here and [ __ ] like it's different yeah
when i walked by those stores in like
high school i was just i just thought
like it was oh they opened it up in the
wrong place because
i don't know anyone that's gonna buy
this [ __ ]
that's true that [ __ ] would work in the
valley or something like if you had a
store
full of cortez's it'd be [ __ ] sold
out every single dude i remember in high
school i remember like
there was a there was it was a pretty
wide demographic it was mostly like kind
of some hood kids most of the time that
was like most of the kids that went
there but all like the hood black kids
it started with them dressing like you
know like bag of your clothes but then
there was a point in time where there
was a transition where they started
wearing abercrombie
and like just like certain pieces yeah
kinda kinda and like skinnier jeans and
then that was like okay this is cool now
and then the whole school kind of like
started to to dress like that and then
have pieces where they would wear like
skinny jeans or they would start wearing
like abercrombie hoodies every now and
then but i remember like for me it was
always i always thought like abercrombie
was for like
rich white kids that lived in like costa
mesa or some [ __ ] that's true because
where i grew up i think any working
class whether it's south bay
sgv if you're in l.a right
i think cholo
skaters and then even like the black
gangs and whatever that was all together
it was very the style was really similar
and that's considered what like
streetwear everywhere everyone wore
dickies everyone had a pair of chucks
everyone had some cortez scissors or
something it's just they styled it
differently like the mexicans would wear
the socks and then the long shorts or
whatever and then but everyone had
flannels everyone had a web belt
bandanas whatever it was whether you're
white skater or whatever asian thug
whatever um all the working class like
you know
we all dressed like we went to the
[ __ ] swap me to get our clothes yeah
and then slawson yeah and it was just
the rich kids that went to the mall and
get like abercrombie or [ __ ] and we
just said you dressed white right yeah
and that's that's one thing i was and
that's why i think representation's
actually a big [ __ ] deal because like
back then i i remember being jealous
that like
white people like or white guys that
were good looking as a default could get
by on just being good people yeah i was
like [ __ ] man like i want to just be a
good dude too but like no i got to be
interesting yeah and i have a backstory
a criminal
what do you mean i'm just minding my own
business you're a [ __ ]
that's why i give it up to like [ __ ]
gin the emcee like when he first was in
rough riders and caused all that thing
like seeing like bad or like kind of
like edgy asians in media was like such
a big [ __ ] deal
yeah it was cool
[Music]
oh
[Music]